la ville de châteaulin dans le finistère
envahi par la pomme de terre des
agriculteurs ont déversé 400 tonnes de
patates dans les rues et devant la
permanence de deux candidats socialistes
et udf c'est énorme mais leurs collègues
du morbihan ont fait mieux ils en ont
déversé 2000 tonnes à pontivy jacques
devaux
heures ce matin tous les accès de
pontivy était bloqué par des tracteurs
chargés de 3000 tonnes de pommes de
terre invendus en ville les commerçants
en signe de solidarité avaient baissé
leur rideau en début d'après-midi les
quelques 300 tracteurs ont convergé vers
le centre-ville les agriculteurs ont
alors déversé une partie de leur
chargement dans les rues une nouvelle
fois ils demandent 55 millions de francs
pour couvrir la moitié des pertes liées
à la surproduction ou actuellement j'ai
perdu je l' ai vendu que 17 tonnes de
plants qui sont partis pour avait mon
collector et depuis j'ai 230 tonnes qui
vont venir c'est l'uruguay qui vit donc
moi au niveau de mon exploitation ça me
fait 150 mille francs de perdus on n'est
pas là pour casser les affaires mais au
moins qu'on lui donne quelque chose pour
y
faire fortune non moins que moi pour
vous dire heureusement ma femme
travaille à l'extérieur jeu sinon mes
enfants n'auraient pas manger manger des
pommes de terre du matin au soir les
raisons de cette surproduction sont
liées à des rendements exceptionnels
mais aussi à la perte du marché irakien
des exportations qui n'ont pas été
compensées nous avons demandé une aide
dès le mois d'octobre aux pouvoirs
publics pour pouvoir exporter sur les
pays de l'est mais c'est peut-être des
jeunes venus en fin d'après midi malgré
l'appel à la dispersion quelques
agriculteurs restaient sur place il a
fallu l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre pour les disperser et dégager
les accès à la ville